no no no when the pom-poms our son was
alive there was no need for anyone else
to be able to buy the finished you
realize an attempt on the discussion
that I'm a different person what I'm
saying to you
let me be clear 6511 your head yeah well
let me hide the ones who are never had
men straight before if we say that this
means what powers are premature freed I
have not had periods before yeah we can
accept this no problem
yeah I'll accept that purse at that
interpretation I'll say fine what does
it say in the verse that they can have
sex with the man it doesn't say that
I've SAT before the Quran max explicitly
clear in total no it says that if in the
Quran it says that if you have touched
her then you have if you have touched
her then you don't have to give her my
heart back in other words her dowry back
if you haven't touched her then and you
divorce her then you know you don't have
to get you give them a model back in
other words it's conceivable - excuse me
it's conceivable to marry and not touch
yeah and that is a form of marriage
which existed is actually not a marriage
it's a in vernacular term to refer to as
the contract of some sort so I'm saying
is it's not
yeah so I'm saying about sex exactly
thank you very much someone who
understands a little bomb fantasy so
here
yeah that's fine just leave em he says
chat he's a young he's a young man
obviously all the ladies are very
attractive very attractive okay so
having said that what I'm trying to say
is this is that so when the quran says
were lemme ahead this is that if we put
Jamar at Villa we'll put all the leaves
together which we have to tell apart the
same method then you'll find that the
Koran says yes the ones you who have
never had before you but it also says
hadith says Allah Allah Allah Allah
which is the high that which means you
can't harm or reciprocity which is the
principle that everyone uses to say that
you can't have intercourse work with
someone professional unable the second
thing they use is
[Music]
we had this discussion before that some
things are not like the Constitution the
Quran is like the Constitution and the
hadith is like the laws so what yeah you
need elaboration that's why I say to
kana load I actually made this argument
you're making I said that if you only
took a Quranic understanding then it
would be permissible for you to have sex
with minors we wait to get away from
that is to have hadith expire expansion
if you only took the Quran you're right
if the Quran was the only thing I have a
video on this with carnal owners if you
only looked at the Quran based on the
version of Quran 65 for it would be
permissible to have sex with minors but
what I'm saying is that we don't just
say Quran so we take ADIZ and as a
result of that because of the actions of
a prophet and he's saying that you can't
harm anyone the jurists have says for
example I've mentioned with dairy in his
book aliens off and his chapter of
Hadoop he mentions anyone who has sex
with someone who's under the age of
puberty yeah we merge there whipped so
another words they flogged in public now
there's a question is it the scholars he
said the humblest call is there
different some said that is they all
whipped and some say they're not with
the point is this is that why is he
talking about punishment in marriage
yeah so so this is something what I'm
saying is Islam is actually the only
religion and my understanding is first
of the Abrahamic religions which makes
it so explicitly clear that in fact
having intercourse with unable people
where would I be - or not by the way
because there could be someone who's a
mental mentally ill or by the way like
in the law now can I ask you a question
how I have sex of a 75 year old me yeah
it's legal but if I had I guarantee if I
have sex with oh sorry sorry but no from
me serve some more okay no sir you so no
no not me listen what I'm saying is what
is it illegal
no it's Haram though is Haram
what I'm saying is that the
one-size-fits-all policy of okay 1560 a
model I don't care about that I'm not
even against the age of consent but I'm
saying that they should be it should be
more nuanced look no problem I'm saying
it's more nuanced innocence I'm saying
that look in the day and age we live in
now I actually would I would put it to
you and I made this argument before of
Ali we said that look because there's
more than one factor would write as a
marriage that had control which means
ability it's a matter of issue had mr.
Walker if she had means scholarly
ability and to to the son just won't
forget
some places only needs exegesis and the
scholars come together and you said some
Arabic words and they come together in
it so I am asking over timing so at the
time of the Prophet obviously there
weren't huge schools of scholars there
were just hundreds and they should do as
well here's what here's what people that
understand here's what people are
understand about I just wanted to say to
you before his long assist you look
every environment is different okay
Islam is not the Islamic rule is not a
rock in the sense that it's unmarriable
unflexible and in the sense this there
is a degree of elasticity and that's
what our soul is all about is to see
okay what works well in this situation
what counts as harm in this situation
what counts as necessity in this
situation and the answers to that
question is different so for me now if
you if I bring someone my man
I say look we've go to a primary school
year six yeah yes sir five years ago we
have five year six yeah ten eleven year
olds yeah if we go to those ages and
I've shown you I promise you anywhere in
London anyway the UK or any of these
kids ready for marriage
absolutely not what the fingers are sick
mind you don't know but my name is
Manuel be honest yeah
all right so me a new wife the reason
why is this interest we would both say
that contradicts your ability yeah so I
would harm them yes okay anything that
harms or anybody is I'm not allowed
married yeah it's not allowed alright so
because the the Qaeda that we have which
is similar to our liberal fingers
women should join this is what I say to
you look this is what Porsche real
consequentialism yeah question why is it
wrong to have sex or one euro second for
now I'm sorry to say but we love Jesus
as well now we do it's the same person
what is it for now listen discussion all
right Baz message Jesus is that look if
it's you're saying it's wrong primarily
because of the harm the consequences of
it perfect I totally agree with you
right so all I'm saying is that if this
I love will call a positive reasoning
did not exist and it wouldn't be wrong
perfect so it's consequentially wrong if
you can ensure it something which is
partially wrong something which is
intuitively wrong is not always it's not
as always categorically wrong
now you can have something like let me
explain you could have something which
is intuitively wrong
what consequentially well you can have
something what it's consequentially
wrong which means it's the 1 because X Y
Z you can explain why right now I'm
saying that with that explanation I
agree with you if you don't have that
explanation I then we say it's not one
anymore therefore therefore therefore
I'm one positing to use a scientific
approach I'm saying to you that if the
person's age is 15
yeah it could be wrong depending on that
person if she's 16 it could be wrong I'm
Kimora Lee morally look if you've got a
16 year old I'm saying it could be wrong
yeah and it could be right yeah
depending on that person only just that
person themselves it could be it could
be wrong could be wrong right depends on
what the variable depends what if it
harms them or not what legal is a
different story that's a different
reason
no problem in this case that's in this
country by the way yeah 14:12
yeah no problem so having said one
person exactly no problem so what I'm
saying to you is this is that if you say
it's wrong because of your hum factor
yeah yeah yeah perfect yeah I'm saying
to you I agree with you look Islamic
roots of you yeah Islamic rules of you
so I'm saying so long as that cause is
not there no more then we can't say it's
wrong no society is decided like you
said because if you really think about
that hey you know when did this change
it changed my it 29 yeah yeah when you
had the Marriage Act change before 2012
too
women didn't venture right anyway into
no problem
but the point is here's what I'm saying
to you before the age of 40 year 1929
before that parrot a legal paradigm
shift no no it was 12 years old yeah if
you look at the Marriage Act 1929 with
12 years old before that time what I'm
saying to you is that was it the case
that all women that were having
intercourse at that age were harmed
correct
it's just there's no need for that you
can't prove the opposite no the burden
of proof is on the one who's making the
claim yeah I'm making it that you're
asking the question were they all
damaged and I would say okay um not
maybe some ridiculous you're still
thinking ease quickly no no I'm not
saying that I've all I'm saying to you
look if you get an 11 year olds
testimony at the in the know but then if
you're saying no no problem but if
you're saying that is the case that
there was a wide-scale epidemic harm of
women because of that or men for them
are you know what you have to finish
this point the point is that this is and
one thing is you can't possibly prove
all women under the age of 16 are
definitely not having said that if you
go to what you have to do is a story and
then this is I'll let me give you
someone and you mind if I just finished
the sentence please
right now I just have me finish the
sentence then you can say what you want
what I'm saying is this is that if you
wanted to do a historical project which
is done in many universities in London
in the UK in the US and in the Western
world the effect of let's say preteen
marriage yeah for the sake of argument
the effects a preteen marry pre teen
marriage on women or girls or whatever
on females mutual language no no just
let me finish something and you would
have to like what I'm telling you what
you would do academically you do you'd
make good
no I'm giving an example right so you'd
have something like the effects of
preteen marriage on X Society and go on
females and exercise from a from time x6
time why then you have to go and get
micro historical reports of like diary
entries err I'm also her harmed and
wherever now I'm saying to you if you
can produce this evidence and actually
take it to consideration account that's
the point
that's impossible right exactly
brilliant so we're come to conclusion
now so if it's not all then it's
conceivable possibly that a thousand
years ago that attended nine ten year
olds would not be harmed in these ways
that's that's what I'm saying that's
always aim
okay guys ready okay
the Prophet was married I should have
Cynthia okay before the Prophet cosmic
marriage at 9 it is no problem we want
to make her gets a big 8 you know 7 huh
yeah okay okay okay now we believe we
believe we're support this is very easy
it's the Prophet because I saw at the
age of seven this brothers you can see
in action right because firstly the for
marriage contract secondly the Prophet
divorced her before she was menstruating
yeah so there's no argument here that
the Quran says that you can mate
he's been freedom he's going through
other scholars at Huntsman unsealed you
very clearly the prophets marriage -
Aisha you know where he says the inter
period for a girl that's not
menstruating argument okay
the Prophet married I shot at 6:00 and
he consummated at night if we believe
that she started means to another area
it's the public divorce turn at the age
of seven she is a woman that's been
divorced dies Norman's treating they
said his cross
yeah
so what seems lunar but you guys are
trying to see that ones thank you guys
very much so in the Quran it says that
will reward and it's led by Jose
so understand you can
[Laughter]